hello everyone this is a special  announcement as I'm going to have a  little talk with Lila chess expert and  programmer Jacob Wilkins we're going to  talk about how Lila chess and offer zero  became such an important part of our  chess culture and we're going to discuss  the details of what makes Lila and offer  chess so special and for that we need  your help help with questions and  comments that you can post down below  and also you can send that info at st.  Louis chess club calm so there we will  be able to answer your questions and if  this will be live-streamed you can ask  us questions while we're having this  discussion with Jacob like share  subscribe and see you on the livestream  [Music]